more than 100 days since Liz truss's
Premiership came to an abrupt end
roundly blamed for damaging the economy
seeing the man she beat willed in to
clean up the mess does today's IMF
report reflect your economic plan
mistrust do you still think it's better
than rishi's it is perhaps no surprise
Britain's shortest serving prime
minister has been keeping a low profile
until now
in a 4 000 word essay for the telegraph
Liz trust has laid out her version of
events blaming the left-wing economic
establishment she says I still believe
that seeking to deliver the original
policy prescription on which I'd fought
the leadership election was the right
thing to do but the forces against it
were too great I'm not claiming to be
blameless in what happened she says but
fundamentally I was not given a
realistic chance to enact my policy by
very powerful economic establishment
coupled with a lack of political support
I assumed upon entering Downing Street
that my mandate would be respected and
accepted how wrong I was I do feel sorry
for her I have to say but from the
street we were at rugby yesterday and we
think maybe probably a less chance that
I come back to England to the studios
not everyone agrees Liz truss had to
stand down because her policies were
incoherent and unsustainable and the
idea she's been brought down by a
left-wing economic establishment which
has been brought down by straightforward
economics if you want to borrow money as
she did and people don't think your
plans mean you can pay it back well
they're not going to lend you that money
there are a few who imagine a Liz trust
returned to Frontline politics anytime
soon but what does all of this mean for
the man who replaced her the problem for
Rishi sinak is what Liz truss is saying
does tap into a mood among some
conservative back benchers impatient for
tax cuts you think the pendulum has
swung too far since Rishi sunak became
prime minister as one senior
conservative put it to me no one sees
Liz truss as a returning Messiah but I
do want to see a plan for growth and
with a budget looming next month
ministers are under pressure I
completely agree with Liz's instinct to
have a lower tax economy what we also
know is if you do that before you've
dealt with inflation and dealt with the
debt then you end up in in difficulty
you can't get the growth out of nowhere
but three former Prime Ministers still
in the Commons too so recently ousted
looming over Rishi sunak is
uncomfortable a political Revival for
Liz truss doesn't help the man who
replaced her Ali Fortescue Sky News
Westminster